[Musique]
150 enfants réunis sur le parvis du
prisme et un flash mob pour lancer les
festivités
il montre au public le travail de toute
une année scolaire danse à l'école il ya
plusieurs classes sur l'agglo où il ya
des artistes qui viennent dans les
classes et qu'ils proposent
une sensibilisation à la danse
contemporaine on leur apprend à être
libres émancipées à avoir le regard
critique et à être capable d'inventer
c'est un projet en direction des jeunes
du territoire de saint quentin
porté par l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines dans lequel des
jeunes gens on va dire de la grande
section de maternelle au lycée découvre
le plaisir de partager la danse avec les
autres dans leur classe c'est très
important avec des danseurs
professionnels les jambes à huit
artistes danseurs ont été sollicités
cette année danse à l'école leur fait
découvrir le rôle de spectateur mais
aussi d'artistes grâce à des ateliers
ont rien à faire est une danse et
pourrait s'étirer
s'entraîner on
c 'est un peu relax comme ça et tu te
sens bien ma kapo o merci on a fait des
eaux groupe e après on se rencontre et
on faisait on faisait des danses ce que
tu peux apprendre de nouveaux mouvements
je connais delvaux et tu peux connaître
des nouveaux personnes des danseuses et
des danseurs
cette année treize classes et 380 élèves
ont participé à cette 19ème édition